the bomb is the terrorists weapon of
choice anytime a bomb happens to the
United States I personally feel that
it's a failure in our part we want to
actually disrupt or dismantle this
attack from ever taking place my name is
Greg Karl I currently serve as the
director of T TAC or the terrorist
explosive device analytical Center in
Teaneck what we do is we leverage the
capabilities of the traditional Forensic
Sciences that have been used for for
decades some of the things we can learn
is the tactics you know that maybe was
used to employ that device you know some
of the material that was used into
making these IEDs since the inception of
t DAC over ten years ago we've received
over 100,000 submissions you know of
IEDs from from around the world inside
of each one of these boxes there was a
different bombing submission from from a
different incident the Boston Marathon
bombing we examined the Northwest 253
the attack when the airline is flying
into Detroit with the so-called
underwear bomber and during the heart of
Iraq and Afghanistan this place was
pretty crazy I mean we were getting over
800 submissions a month that were coming
through the doors here
by biometrically exploiting these
devices it allows us to help watch less
these individuals preventing them from
coming to the United States because we
know that their fingerprints have been
on IEDs from other parts of the world
we've identified over 1,000 individuals
with potential ties to terrorism we've
nominated over a hundred people to the
National terrorist watch list which
actually prevents those individuals from
entering the country our biggest
challenge is to stay as far left a boom
as possible I don't care how our
information is use as long as it is used
for the better protection of the
homeland and any United States